j'ai un sentiment bizarre qui mélange de
la grande fierté est en même temps un
petit peu de un peu de tristesse que de
fierté quand même j'ai deux annonces à
vous faire aujourd'hui je vous en faire
une a tout de suite et une à la fin de
la vidéo vous le savez peut-être fin
2015 j'ai sorti ma bande dessinée roger
essais humains dessinés par paca c'était
fou pour moi de faire cette bande
dessinée quelques années après j'ai
sorti le tome 2 de rejet c'est humain
avec encore plus actions puissent
d'enjeux dramatiques super tenant est
désormais roger c'est humain le tome 3
est disponible partout dans les
librairies en ligne vous pouvez cliquer
sur un lien dans la description pour le
commander par excellent tome dont je
suis le plus fier puisque c'est là où il
ya le plus de davanture d'émotion de
voyage les personnages vont japon
regardez comme c'est beau il ya plein de
vannes et des trucs que j'ai vraiment
vécu au japon par exemple ailleurs il ya
une édition avec des stickers intérieur
vous pouvez retrouver chez cultura et
c'est également le dernier tome d'un
roger c'est humain donc c'est la fin de
roger ces humains en bande dessinée vous
avez bien entendu en bande dessinée
je pourrais faire d'autres tomes mais
j'ai préféré m'arrêter sur celui ci pour
plusieurs raisons j'ai fait le premier
tome c'était vraiment un rêve de gamin
de pouvoir créer sa bande dessinée
c'était vraiment génial je savais que je
vais faire un deuxième tome quand j'ai
fait le deuxième tome
je savais que je voulais en faire un
troisième et quand j'ai fait ce
troisième tome je savais que ça allait
être le dernier ce que quand je crée
quelque chose j'aime bien explorer
j'aime bien tester des nouveaux trucs me
mettre un petit peu en danger
c'était le cas pour cette bande dessinée
et si je faisais un quatrième tome je
pense que je mettrais pas autant de moi
j'ai pu faire dans les précédents tomes
c'est bon c'est important pour ça que
j'aime bien faire plein de projets
différents comme du court métrage du
live du jeu vidéo de la bande dessinée
du dessin animé c'est ce qui me stimule
en fait et j'ai pas envie de tomber dans
une lassitude c'est voilà c'est mon
choix de vie mais entre temps je me suis
attaché aux personnages
je me suis attaché à roger à hugo à
florence à charles lepers à la
belle-mère pascal ou même aux animaux de
compagnie c'est bizarre mais maintenant
quand je vois les personnages et j'ai
même pas l'impression c'est moi qui les
ai créé l'impression qu'ils existent
vraiment et si c'est la fin de roger ces
humains en bande dessinée prendre c'est
le début de roger c'est humain sous
d'autres formes déjà vous allez le
dessin animé qui est disponible toutes
les semaines gratuitement sur youtube et
on se donne à fond pour pouvoir faire
une saison de l'année prochaine avec 40
nouveaux époux
je vous annonce que je suis en train de
travailler sur une nouvelle forme de
l'histoire de relever ces humains la
forme la plus ambitieuse je peux pas
trop vous en dire pour l'instant c'est
vous dites mais de quoi il parle mais
quand je vous ferai l'annoncent très
bientôt vous allez vous dire ah ouais
d'accord je veux bien qu'on prend tout
est lié tout s'explique
j'ai envie de voir ces personnages
encore très longtemps sous plateforme
c'est très important pour moi maintenant
je fais la deuxième annonce je sais pas
si vous savez mais quand j'ai sorti le
tome 1 et le tome 2 je suis allé faire
des dédicaces partout en france pour moi
c'est hyper important d'aller rencontrer
le public parce que je travaille des
mois dessus et c'est pas pour l'ignorer
de mettre en rayon merci au revoir non
au contraire moi j'ai besoin de
rencontrer les lecteurs de vous le
présenter
qu'on fasse une photo ensemble bref pour
moi les dédicaces et un moment hyper
important et je vais pas vous mentir
c'est un peu un drame cette année de ne
pas pouvoir les faire à cause d'eux des
raisons sanitaires que vous connaissez
également j'avoue je suis dépité
habituellement barrage aller partout
quoi à marseille lille j'ai les mêmes en
belgique
je vais aller en suisse pour faire les
dédicaces et là je me retrouve comme un
con à dire est commandé le où elle est
en librairie
on peut pas se voir du coup on a branché
tous les neurones notamment avec
l'éditeur dupuis pour essayer de créer
comme des dédicaces sont dédicace je
m'explique avec paca le dessinateur
on a dédicacé 150 bande dessinée qu'on
va planqué dans plat de librairies
partout en france et quand je dis plein
s'est plaint s'affiche la liste tout de
suite de toutes les librairies
on envoie un tome dédicacé aux libraires
qui va le planquer parmi les autres
roger c'est humain premier arrivé
premier servi c'est un petit peu la
surprise d'ailleurs si vous tombez sur
une de ces bd dédicaces et n'hésitez pas
à me tagué sur instagram
voilà pour que j'ai la preuve que les bd
sont bien arrivés dans vos mains
d'ailleurs on avait fait pas mal de
dédicaces en live sur twitter avec paca
pour voilà un petit peut interagir avec
vous avoir un peu vos idées sur savoir
quoi dessiner dans l'est dans les tomes
je suis même allé mettre moi-même des bd
des dédicaces et dans pas mal de
librairies indépendantes dans paris
tranquillement discrètement premier
arrivé premier servi
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jours
c'est reparti
[Musique]
j'espère que cet homme dédicaces et vont
arriver entre de bonnes mains
malheureusement c'est tout ce qu'on a
trouvée pour essayer d'avoir une
interaction avec vous pendant cette
crise sanitaire pense que c'est mieux
que rien et j'espère que dès que la
situation le permettra je pourrai
refaire des vrais dédicaces partout en
france parce que pour moi c'est
important
voilà de rencontrer les lecteurs sur le
e tome dont je suis le plus fier là le
dernier tome de roger et c'est humain
est disponible absolument partout dans
les librairies fnac cultura
vous pouvez également le commander sur
internet il rien dans la description
c'est en quelque sorte pour moi une page
qui se tourne une page de bande dessinée
c'est à dire que c'est la fin d'une page
et le début d'une nouvelle également se
détestent les genoux [ __ ] pourrait
jouer ça j'espère qu'elle va vous plaire
et regardez ceux ci les trois tomes
c'est ma grande grande fierté merci à
dupuy merci à paca merci à la mx les
faits la couleur vous avez réalisé un de
mes rêves est bien évidemment merci à
vous les lecteurs acheté cette bande
dessinée à très vite sur internet
[Musique]